[Music]
if you are a product manager if you are
a product product owner if you are a new
x user experience designer if you are a
chief data officer or if you are a ceo
uh you have to wake up and to digitize
and to transform and the digital
transformation program is
a very useful tool to help you to do it
so my name is liliana i'm came from
paris france
and i actually working i'm working in
digital performance
in a tech banking company a large
corporation in france my day-to-day work
is to
to mobilize
cross-functional teams
in order to create more
value for our internal customers and
also for the end users
our customers are more and more
digital consumers they are more
empowered they want to
save time and business and money i've
already practiced the digital
transformation in our company
but with
the digital transformation of stanford i
wanted to validate
that
that we are trying to operate is in a
good direction and also
to
to try to get new insights new ideas
about
how to be more nimble with the teams
how to be
more
data centric
how to be more
product platform oriented with new
business models
and of course how to innovate
every day how to prototype
before
launching
products the digital transformation
program from stanford helped me help me
to
be more productive
productive and effective
with the cross-functional teams
i'm
very glad to
to use the the methods the the practices
and the tools
um
in my
in this i'm in my environment in this
context
it's really helped me it was amazingly
powerful
for me
you